what would happen if you somehow had
space bending abilities
and decided to test them out by placing
the earth between the two asteroid belts
in our solar system
well the short answer is you might be
asking for a little dose of planetary
extinction
would earthlings be forced to give up on
celestial travel
how long before one of these belts
asteroids is headed our way
and how big a space rock could we
collide with
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth was sandwiched between
two asteroid belts
our solar system has two asteroid belts
closest to us is the main asteroid belt
located between mars and jupiter its
asteroids are primarily made of rock and
stone
it's estimated that 16 of them have a
diameter greater than 240 kilometers
the largest object in the belt is the
dwarf planet series
uh more on how this factors into the big
picture
later
all the way in the back beyond neptune
lies the kuiper belt
a region filled with icy leftovers from
the early days of the solar system
some with a diameter of 100 kilometers
or more
among them lives another dwarf planet
maybe you've heard of it pluto
so
what would earth's fate be surrounded by
not one but two asteroid belts
hey if you're looking for even more
thought-provoking questions and
mind-blowing experiences you need to
check out one dream yeah the folks that
brought you the great courses plus are
back with even more
bold educational experiences through
documentaries travelogues tutorials and
how to's
no matter where your mind wanders they
have you covered in curated video
collections made by experts in their
fields and with earth day just around
the corner now is a great time to check
out solving for xero the search for
climate innovation based on the
best-selling book from bill gates
this series opened my eyes on how
materials we take for granted like
concrete and steel can contribute to
climate change and the strides we can
make to reduce carbon emissions
you know every day is a journey for
knowledge and right now you can join me
on this quest with a free trial by
visiting wonderium.com
what if show click on the link in the
description below to start your free
trial today
your brain will fall in love with one
dream but those asteroid belts yeah
maybe not so much
to understand the scale of this scenario
you first need to know what an
astronomical unit is
well one astronomical unit or au is the
distance between the earth and the sun
the kuiper belt is 25 au wide
compare that to the main asteroid belt
which is only one au
pretty sparse
ok well let's say you left their sizes
as is and transported them next to earth
the inner edge of the kuiper belt would
be between mars and us
the main asteroid belt's outer edge
would be situated between earth and
venus
the main asteroid belt although the
smaller of the two would still extend
itself over the sun
venus and mercury would now orbit among
its millions of rocky bodies
the kuiper belt on the other side would
go even further
you'd find it draping itself over mars
jupiter saturn and uranus
only neptune would be left outside of
the party
though not by much
now how would this new arrangement look
on a starry night
well uh quite unexciting i'm afraid
well think of it this way pluto the
dwarf planet inside the kuiper belt
would now orbit at about 3 a.u from us
just shy of our current distance from
jupiter
jupiter is an enormous gas planet but is
no more than a bright star to the naked
eye so
what can you expect to see of pluto
which is only two-thirds the diameter of
our moon yeah a whole lot of nothing
really
by this point you're realizing that you
used your powers irresponsibly
after all it would be crazy to travel to
other planets within our solar system
now that they're surrounded by millions
upon millions of scattered objects
so
would you be stuck on earth forever
well no
there might be millions even billions of
rocks floating too close to our planet
now
but luckily for you asteroid belts
aren't that dense
the average distance between objects
inside a belt is about 1 million
kilometers
so you'd still be able to fulfill your
dream of going to mars one day
that is unless you squeezed the asteroid
belts really tight
the entire main asteroid belt
would now fit between earth and venus
and the kuiper belt between earth and
mars
sure we aren't strangers to flying
through junk
in 2021 alone there were about 23 000
pieces of debris larger than a softball
orbiting earth
only now we wouldn't be surrounded by
pieces left behind by broken satellites
we'd have to deal with substantially
larger chunks of all-natural material
the kuiper belt alone has hundreds of
thousands of objects at least 100
kilometers wide
think about it hundreds of thousands of
asteroids each at least 10 times bigger
than the one that wiped out the
dinosaurs 66 million years ago
and in the main asteroid belt we'd be
facing over a million rocks larger than
one kilometer
on top of millions of other small ones
so yeah there space travel would be
suspended indefinitely
maybe we could at least use all those
asteroids for something helpful like
iron and nickel mining right
well not so fast you'd be pretty busy
dealing with asteroids bombarding earth
from all directions yeah you heard that
right the gravitational pull from our
planet could attract objects from both
of the surrounding belts
at the lower end of this mass
destruction scale you'd have smaller
asteroids capable of destroying an
entire metropolis with the same amount
of force as a nuclear bomb
and remember ceres
the dwarf planet inside the main
asteroid belt yeah well it's almost 100
times larger than the asteroid that led
to the mass extinction of the dinosaurs
one tiny cataclysmic bump into earth and
oops there goes our planet
along with all life as we know it
so
don't play with the solar system unless
you plan on giving humanity a new home
and not wiping us all out in the process
you could try and terraform mars
but
that's a story for another
what if